home israelis and supporters gathered on
the strip last night calling for an
end to that violence sasha loftis shows
us how the local jewish community is
showing support for families suffering
in the middle east
flying flags honking horns and heartfelt
messages
we want to just show our unity show our
voice
show our support are all signs of
community support
as a conflict continues in the middle
east we really just want to show the
world their support out there for israel
hundreds gathered in las vegas wednesday
to band together
as violence flares between israeli and
palestinian forces
my mom my sisters my nephews my cousins
are in shelters and as an israeli
american who live here in the states
i fear for their lives but i also fear
for our life here
as jews in america those here are
standing in solidarity with israel
but hundreds have died on both sides as
the decades-long conflict
reignited a few weeks ago
they hope their presence at home will
shed real light on the issue at hand
it's terrible that we can not really do
anything
except show our support to our country
show our love
and encourage peace for those they love
who are suffering so many miles away
we're strong and we're going to be ok
sasha loftis
8 news now